c'était donc le premier volet de la
série c'était la guerre d'Algérie
consignée par Georges Marc Benhamou et
Benjamin Stora un épisode qui nous
venons de le voir nous éclaire sur ce
que fut la colonisation de l'Algérie par
la France entre 1830 et la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale une colonisation
qui expliquerait pour beaucoup la
fracture mémorielle qui persiste encore
et toujours aujourd'hui entre les deux
pays benjamin storat est maintenant avec
nous sur ce plateau bienvenue à vous
Benjamin Stora nous sommes très heureux
bien sûr de vous recevoir dans cette
émission après avoir vu le premier
épisode de cette série on va rappeler
que vous êtes historien bien sûr
spécialiste de l'histoire du Maghreb de
l'Algérie et particulièrement de cette
fameuse guerre d'Algérie c'est donc vous
qui êtes le co-auteur avec Georges Marc
Benhamou de cette série c'était la
guerre d'Algérie que nous avons le
plaisir de présenter ça sera tout au
long de cette semaine dans cette
émission des Badoc vous êtes l'auteur du
rapport sur les questions mémorielles
portant sur la colonisation et guerre
d'Algérie qui vous avez été commandité
par Emmanuel Macron en juillet 2020 vous
mettrez les remettrez ce rapport six
mois plus tard au chef de l'État vos
propositions pour une réconciliation
mémoriale durable entre les deux pays
figurent dans cet ouvrage France Algérie
les passions douloureuses qu'on peut se
procurer chez Albin Michel puis au
chapitre de vos parutions on citera
aussi histoire dessinée des Juifs
d'Algérie de l'Antiquité à nos jours ça
c'est un ouvrage qui est disponible aux
éditions La Découverte Pascal Blanchard
est également avec nous bienvenue à vous
Pascal Blanchard merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes historien spécialiste du fait
colonial auteur entre autres entre
autres de décolonisation française la
chute d'un empire co-écrit avec Nicolas
Bancel et Sandrine Lemaire un ouvrage
publié aux éditions La Martinière
Benjamin Stora je vous propose d'entrer
tout de suite dans notre sujet qui est
la colonisation durant la période que
nous avons revu à travers ce premier
épisode de votre série et ce qu'on en
garde d'emblée c'est qu'elle a été
violente elle a été longue progressive
cette colonisation à partir de 1830 elle
se traduisit par la disparition du tiers
de la population algérienne entre 1830
et 1850 c'est dire la violence de cette
colonisation
c'est effectivement un épisode
absolument terrible et tragique puisque
on a oublié cette conquête coloniale qui
a duré plus d'admi siècle en fait une
conquête coloniale qui s'est disons
déroulé dans des conditions terribles
avec ce qu'on appelle la pratique des
colonnes infernales qui avaient
d'ailleurs été expérimenté au moment de
la Révolution française contre les
Vendéens mais qui a été mis en
application en Espagne et puis ensuite
en Algérie c'est-à-dire la pratique des
RADIAS des dépossessions foncières et
des mises en captivité de population
entière il y a même eu des enfumades
dont on parle d'ailleurs dans le
documentaire ce qui prouve effectivement
que il y a un souvenir qui est resté
gravé dans la mémoire algérienne qui est
un souvenir terrible de cette conquête
coloniale qui est encore une fois a duré
très longtemps et puis qui s'est traduit
aussi après 1860 70 par un mécanisme de
dépossession foncière qui est très
important parce que la déposition
foncière vous savez la terre était liée
à la question du nom et lorsque vous
perdiez la terre quelque part vous
perdiez aussi votre identité de votre
nom et des tribus entre guillemets
entières des familles entières se sont
trouvés brusquement privé de noms de
sorte qu'on les a appelés les 100 non
pas trop mimiques les SNP je reparle de
tout cela d'ailleurs dans mon rapport
c'est à dire qu'à la dépossession
j'allais presque dire physique est venu
s'ajouter une déposition culturelle une
des possession identitaire nominale qui
est très très grave très importante et
qui explique aussi toutes sortes de
perturbations disons
identitaire qui ont pu exister puis en
même temps
la colonisation c'est l'arrivée d'une
population nouvelle ce sont les
Européens d'Algérie ce qu'on va appeler
les Européens c'est-à-dire les Italiens
principalement et les Espagnols qui sont
les deux grands groupes venant de la
Méditerranée du côté de l'oralie d'un
côté de du Constantinois et de
l'Algérois de l'autre et puis aussi bien
sûr les Alsaciens Lorrains qui vont
venir s'établir en Algérie notamment
après la perte de l'Alsace horaire en
1870 et puis aussi dans cette population
européenne n'oublions pas sans le on l'a
peut souligner ceux qui ont été ce qu'on
appelle entre guillemets les Réprouvés
c'est à dire les républicains de 1848
les communards de 1871 ce qui refusait
l'ordre établi qui était des sortes de
rebelles de dissidents et même des
fouriéristes des saint-cymoniens
c'est-à-dire des utopistes du 19e siècle
qui sont venus tenter l'aventure
algérienne dans cette sensude en fait
qui paraissait à la fois très proche de
la France très loin parce qu'il
symbolisait ce Sud aussi une sorte
d'Orion d'Orient lointain mais en même
temps très proche de l'Europe et de la
ce peuplement d'ailleurs de
l'Algérie tel que vous décrivez à
l'instant a été encouragé notamment la
très bien vu dans votre documentaire à
partir de la troisième République et on
y reviendra tout à l'heure et sont
quelques 400000 personnes qui parmi les
populations que vous avez définies
effectivement été en Algérie à la fin de
du 19e siècle Pascal Blanchard ce qu'on
a envie de comprendre parce que les les
cendres les braises sont tellement
incandes lorsqu'il est question du sujet
qui nous concerne aujourd'hui la
colonisation de l'Algérie c'est de
savoir si cette colonisation a été plus
violente en Algérie que dans d'autres
colonisations effectuées par la France
un peu plus tard on pense à l'Afrique
subsaharienne par exemple ou l'Indochine
bien entendu ou par d'autres
grandes puissances colon a commencé
peut-être par les par les Britanniques
où elle se situe dans la hiérarchie des
colonisation et dans la violence auquel
on a assisté à l'occasion de ces
colonisation l'Algérie on va commencer
par le cas français à l'intérieur de cet
Empire français qui se constitue la
violence a été aussi présente dans toute
la conquête de l'Afrique de l'Ouest mais
sur une période en fin de compte sur une
temporalité moins longue en Algérie mais
il y a eu des grands moments plus de
position rappelons-nous de Samory où le
conflit avec sa morille va durer en
Afrique de l'Ouest une décennie
rappelons-nous aussi une qu'enquette
extrêmement violente de Madagascar mais
il n'y a pas que l'Afrique
rappelons-nous la Nouvelle-Calédonie qui
a été une conquête pareil certes à
échelle moins importante qu'en Algérie
vu le territoire mais d'une violence qui
est tout à fait comparable à la violence
qu'on a connu en Algérie et puis il y a
l'Indochine qui est déjà en germe
pendant que ce fait la colonisation de
l'Algérie ce tour de 50 ans dont parlait
Benjamin Stora vous avez par étape la
constitution de l'Indochine française
qui va prendre un temps extrêmement long
et là aussi rappelez-vous le tir
rappelez-vous les textes sur l'Indochine
la violence et tout présente et donc ça
veut dire que un empire qui se constitue
sans violence presque dans la question
pourrait se poser la question de
l'inverse est-ce que ça peut exister
c'est extrêmement rare puisque le XIXe
siècle est insecte d'abord violent
naturellement il l'est les conquêtes
coloniales qu'elles soient l'Empire
britannique de l'Empire allemand ou
l'empire portugais sont des
colonisations ou des pas ce qu'on
appelle à l'époque des pacifications
extrêmement violente il y a peu de
territoires qui rentrent extrêmement
violents vous pouvez l'exemple du Congo
par exemple où il y a eu moins de
conflits mais ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que l'Algérie aussi un
particularisme c'est que c'est un grand
territoire
métropolitaine donc il y a aussi une
volonté
militaire d'imposer sur l'ensemble de
ces radiateurs jusqu'au Sahara c'est
pour ça que ça va prendre extrêmement de
temps voire plus qu'au début du 20e
siècle pour faire qu'il y ait une
pacification terme de l'époque globale
du territoire et puis il y a très tôt
une opposition militaire et politique à
ces colonisation quand vous avez tous
ces ingrédients là avec en plus un
conflit qui était suivi
extraordinairement par la par les médias
on essaie de savoir si la France va
arriver à occuper ces territoires et
puis vous traversez des régimes
extrêmement nombreux faut se rappeler
qu'il y a pas que la Troisième
République le Second Empire et Napoléon
III fait aussi de l'Algérie un
territoire qui est regardé de près parce
que c'est la première d'une certaine
manière des conquêtes du Nouvel Empire
il y a eu cet empire perdu d'Ancien
Régime en gros 1763 et c'est la première
pierre d'un nouvel édifice qui va passer
de monarchie à l'Empire pour ce grand
empire puis après la République la
deuxième et la troisième et va devenir
la pierre angulaire de ce nouvel empire
qui se constitue sur les restes
antillais réunionnais voit les comptoirs
du Sénégal mais qui amènent quelque part
une sorte de devenir coloniale pour la
France pour compléter ce que dit Pascal
Blanchard c'est que nous passons à
travers cette temporalité très longue de
l'esclavage à la colonisation c'est à
dire qu'il y a des logiques de
domination qui continue c'est pour ça
que c'est très difficile de penser
l'histoire de la colonisation parce que
ça s'étale sur 400 ans 4 siècles
d'histoire
siècle d'histoire de la monarchie
l'Empire la République avec cette ce
passage cette circulation pourrait-on
dire de l'esclavage à la colonisation et
c'est ça qui est très difficile à penser
aujourd'hui de sorte que cette longueur
cette durée extraordinaire va fabriquer
ce qu'on pourrait appeler le
nationalisme français c'est à dire que
le National la grande France la plus
grande France et bien elle se fabrique
là au 19e siècle dans la fabrication
d'un nationalisme français qui s'étend
sur des territoires gigantesques un peu
à l'exemple d'ailleurs de l'Empire
britannique qui est le grand concurrent
de la France les Britanniques c'était
vous savez le pays où le soleil ne se
couche jamais c'est encore le cas un
petit peu aujourd'hui peut-être à
travers le Commonwealth mais du point de
vue disons de l'Empire français c'est
colossal ça a été rappelé à l'instant
par escale et l'Indochine au début de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale l'Empire
français représentait un cinquième de la
population mondiale et c'est le deuxième
après l'Empire britannique on va revenir
maintenant sur ce qui était le le
système
colonialiste français en Algérie avec
une très forte discrimination c'est très
bien expliqué dans votre documentaire on
va revoir un extrait
plusieurs sociétés vont vivre côte à
côte dans ce système de domination
coloniale
d'un côté les Européens de l'autre les 3
millions de musulmans qui vont être
soumis en 1881 à un code de l'indigénat
restriction de liberté restriction de
circulation punition collective et
surtout droit de vote restreint à
quelques milliers de notables alors
Benjamin storat évidemment plusieurs
sentiers cohabitent au sein de ce
système de domination coloniale français
mais alors certainement même aujourd'hui
jusqu'à dire que en Algérie on assiste à
une véritable politique ségrégationniste
est-ce que c'est un terme justifié
aujourd'hui les mots ont un sens est-ce
qu'on peut aller jusque là il y avait
une ségrégation qui existait dans la
mesure où par exemple pour prendre un
seul exemple qui est très simple l'accès
à l'éducation était pas le même l'accès
à la citoyenneté n'est pas le même c'est
à dire que la plupart de ce qu'on
appelait les indigènes musulmans
n'avaient pas la possibilité d'accéder
de manière naturelle automatique à la
nationalité française même s'ils étaient
naturellement des autochtones des
indigènes de ce pays c'est quand même
une sacrée inégalité sur le plan
juridique bien entendu c'est très
important de sorte que on a pu parler
pour l'Algérie si on arrive directement
à la Troisième République qu'on a pu
parler d'un faux modèle de la République
c'est ça qui est très compliqué dans
cette histoire algérienne c'est qu'à la
fois il y a cette proclamation de la
devise que nous connaissons tous liberté
égalité fraternité avec naturellement
cette devise inscrite au fronton des
mairies de toutes les mairies de
l'Algérie il y a disons des discours des
proclamations des écoles qui sont
construites et les élèves ceux qui
peuvent y accéder après disons cette
notion d'égalité politique d'égalité
juridique et dans les faits dans la
réalité quotidienne de tous les jours en
fait c'est la logique de séparation qui
domine c'est-à-dire d'être côte à côte
et non pas ensemble et c'est ça le
problème de l'Algérie française c'est
pour ça qu'on a pu parler à un moment
donné de fiction de la République
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait cette sorte
disons de de brouillard idéologique
sur la terre entière ça c'est posé et on
l'apprend vous moi Benjamin on l'a pris
à l'école donc c'est vraiment et puis on
constate que dans la pratique
la troisième lui qui est aussi l'enfant
du 19e siècle et le dixième siècle c'est
que des savants le discours sur les
races le discours sur la différence le
discours aussi sur la mission
civilisatrice et d'un seul coup les deux
discours fonctionnent en même temps
alors aujourd'hui si on prend pas un peu
de temps on a du mal à comprendre de
cette manière Benjamin vient de le dire
chaque individu était d'abord le je
dirais l'objet prisonnier de sa race
c'est comme ça que pense ce système
colonial le système colonial il pense
qu'il y a des guides et qui a ceux qui
doivent suivre il y a ceux qui doivent
arriver à la lumière et à ceux qui sont
dans les ténèbres et tout le système
colonial quel que soit le territoire
fonctionne sur ces principes-là en
Algérie ceci se superpose à deux sujets
essentiels le premier il y a une
migration Benjamin Stora vient de le
dire qu'il vienne et d'Espagne de Malte
d'Italie donc des étrangers et qui vont
devenir français sur le sol d'Algérie
alors que les masques européens
exactement alors que les natifs nés sur
ce sol d'Algérie vont en fonction de
leur communauté religieuse ou raciale de
pas avoir le même destin donc vous
fabriquez une machine à travers ça dont
la base même de la pensée politique et
de dire qu'il doit y avoir des guides et
d'autres qui le sont pas mais qui va
apparent induire la redistribution des
terres qui va induire le droit électoral
qui a le droit de voter qui n'a pas le
droit de voter qui a le droit de
circuler librement le Code civil n'est
pas le même le code avec le code de
l'indigénat exactement il s'impose sur
un 1881 exactement et il est même un des
modèles les plus développés en termes
juridique pour imposer à chaque individu
d'une certaine manière sa place dans la
société c'est pas juste une pratique qui
n'aurait pas été pensée à les pensées
pour les tribunaux les pensées pour les
peines de justice elle est pensée pour
le droit dans sa globalité les pensées
pour le statut même de l'individu homme
ou femme le droit électoral n'est pas un
petit sujet puisque ça va traverser tout
le 20e siècle se débat sur les droits
électoraux et là vous fabriquez quelque
part sur plusieurs générations une
machine inégalitaire puisque le droit
d'une certaine manière va légitimer le
fait de prendre les terres le droit va
légitimer le fait de ne pas être un
électeur et le droit d'une certaine
manière s'inscrit dans une forme de
modernité c'est ça qui aujourd'hui ne
peut nous paraît étrange c'est que tout
ça est légitimé il faudra du temps pour
que ces hommes et ces femmes arrivent à
la lumière et arrivent à la civilisation
c'est ce que la Troisième République a
porté comme le discours emblématique de
son action coloniale la mission
civilisatrice d'amener ses peuples vers
quelque part une forme de lumière qui
amènerait la République alors
aujourd'hui on est totalement tétanisé
quand on voit ça mais à l'époque ce
discours fonctionne de très très grande
cohérence puisque la propagande est là
pour le vendre et pour illustrer ce que
vous dites j'ai noté une phrase
prononcée par par Jules Ferry alors
Jules Ferry c'est une figure
emblématique peut-être avec les ongles
en bétail il y en a d'autres bien
entendu de cette fameuse Troisième
République voilà ce qu'il déclarait le
28 juillet 1885 devant la Chambre des
députés messieurs il faut parler plus
haut et plus frais il faut dire
ouvertement qu'en effet les rats
supérieurs ont un droit vis-à-vis des
races inférieures parce qu'il y a un
devoir pour elle elles ont le devoir de
civiliser les races inférieures voilà
l'état d'esprit de Jules Ferry la toute
fin du du 19e et le 18 alors que
représente une grande partie de ce que
pensent les républicains de l'époque les
bonnets à partir de l'époque les
monarchistes de l'époque c'est à
discours qui dépasse simplement un
discours d'exception c'est la norme
c'est la manière dont on pense le monde
et dans lequel on s'inscrit donc très
naturellement le droit de coloniser au
nom du droit de civilisé et alors pour
oui pardon non c'est ensuite dans la
suite de cela qu'on va naître un anti
colonialisme qui vient du républicanisme
c'est ça toute la difficulté c'est ce
que c'est pas aussi à cause de ça
qu'aujourd'hui la repentance du côté
français n'est pas alors n'est toujours
pas à l'ordre du jour sur cette fameuse
période de la
colonisation entre autres oui je pense
qu'il y a une difficulté à penser
autrement républicain aujourd'hui n'a
pas toutes les difficultés du monde à
remettre en cause à faire le procès il y
a une difficulté une autre République
qui était celle de la troisième il y a
une difficulté à penser la question
coloniale parce qu'il y a une difficulté
à penser à la République c'est-à-dire
que ce qu'on a appelé l'aNTIC
colonialisme de la fin du 19e siècle et
du début du 20e siècle porté par exemple
paradome comme Jaurès ou même par
Clémenceau et bien c'est de faire en
sorte que la question de la mission
civilisatrice héritée des Lumières et de
la Révolution française n'entraînent pas
la misère des populations indigènes donc
il faut rectifier le tir c'est-à-dire
que cette rectification du tir qui
intervient en début du 20e siècle qui va
créer une sorte d'Antic colonialisme
vous allez presque dire dreyfusard
c'est-à-dire qu'au nom des Droits de
l'Homme au nom de la Révolution
française au nom de la République nous
ne pouvons pas poursuivre de cette
manière
la question coloniale et puis il y aura
un autre anti colonialisme qui lui sera
beaucoup plus entre guillemets tiers
mondiste c'est-à-dire qu'il sera dans
une autre dimension c'est-à-dire de
faire en sorte que les populations
colonisées qui vont se libérer seront
porteurs d'une possibilité de changement
disons de société qui serait celle du
socialisme etc donc il y a deux anti
colonialisme qui cohabitent au sein
effectivement d'un seul univers d'un
seul discours et c'est ça qui oblige à
la difficulté de penser la question
coloniale les rendez-vous manqués ils
sont évoqués dans ce documentaire
benjaminstera j'en ai j'en ai j'en ai
noté quelques-uns le royaume arabe un
souhaitait un temps par Napoléon III et
puis cette fameuse Troisième République
avec à l'intérieur de la Troisième
République le Front populaire par
exemple ce fameux plan et ce projet de
loi violette Bloom nous sommes en 36
c'est le Front populaire c'est une
volonté d'une émancipation des peuples
j'aurais pu aussi citer la création de
l'Assemblée algérienne ça on est un peu
plus tard on est en 47 avec un double
collège électoral alors évidemment ça
pouvait difficilement se terminer par un
système égalitaire entre les Européens
on va dire et les non-européens les
rendez-vous manqués qu'est-ce qu'on peut
en dire sur le Second Empire et le
royaume arabe il y a une forme de
mythologie d'un rêve d'une Méditerranée
par la France là on a encore dans un
mythe des élites occidentales le
rendez-vous manqué de la prêt Première
Guerre mondiale est intéressante puisque
les Algériens notamment ont donné leur
sang pour la France entre 150 et 160 000
Algériens en tout cas non européen
ont participé à cette première guerre
mondiale dans les rangs français là il y
avait quelque part une occasion
incroyable surtout que juste avant la
Première Guerre mondiale tout un
mouvement réformiste émerge et puis vous
avez le projet Bloom violette qui va
marquer quelque part la volonté
réformiste d'une partie des socialistes
français et des communistes avec cette
commission d'enquête avec cette volonté
à ce moment-là un mouvement qui va être
totalement bloqué d'abord par les
parties d'extrême droite de l'époque PSF
notamment les hommes de Laroque va être
bloqués par le grand Colonna en Algérie
et va échouer lamentablement au
Parlement ça va traîner 18 mois cette
affaire et on n'était pas pour le droit
de vote à donner à tous les Algériens
c'était uniquement va 25000 algériens
d'élite qui aurait eu le droit de vote
donc vous voyez que la difficulté à
l'époque de réformer même pour le Front
populaire fait que les rendez-vous
manqués ils sont aussi que les élites en
place les élites politiques locales par
exemple ou les parties nationalistes de
l'époque et de droite refusent
systématiquement toute volonté même de
changement même je dirais un tant soit
peu du système colonial donc oui c'est
des rendez-vous manqués mais c'était des
rendez-vous impossibles totalement
impossible le grand Colonna évoqué un
instant par Pascal Blanchard c'est
grand-collons qui reviennent souvent au
devant de la scène lorsqu'il est
question de changer la donne sur place
la donne société en Algérie qui sont ces
grands colons et
ont-ils fait échouer tous ces
rendez-vous manqués les grands colons
justement en grande partie oui bien sûr
ils étaient surtout dans le commerce
maritime c'est eux qui tenaient le
pouvoir économique entre dire les choses
comme ça représentants il y avait un
parti colonial à l'Assemblée nationale
française c'était évident mais dans le
cas de l'Algérie on peut pas simplement
parler que des gros colons et assimiler
avec cette notion de gros colon
l'ensemble des Européens d'Algérie parce
qu'il y a eu une confusion sur la grosse
colonisation et la masse de européen
d'Algérie qui eux avaient un niveau de
vie inférieur à celui de la métropole et
c'est ça qui rendait toute la difficulté
de la situation c'est que en fait cette
masse
d'Européen d’algérie qui adhéré
profondément à l'Algérie française et
donc il ne voyait pas la possibilité
d'une Algérie disons indépendante ça
c'est évident et bien cette masse là
aussi elle espérait dans une sorte
d'Algérie fraternelle égalitaire mais
toujours lié à la France je pense bien
sûr à la personnalité d'Albert Camus qui
est une sorte de personnalité
emblématique de cette masse des
Européens d’algérie qui était ce qu'on
pourrait appeler entre guillemets des
libéraux en fait et donc pensez
uniquement la question de l'Algérie et
de la colonisation en termes de grosses
de gros colons à mon avis c'est un peu
simplification pour être précis parce
que
toute la difficulté de la décolonisation
de l'Algérie à la différence du Maroc de
l'Indochine du Sénégal etc c'est la
masse de ce million d'Européens qui sont
là enracinés depuis cinq six générations
et qui sont pas des gros colons mais qui
sont des petits fonctionnaires qui sont
des gens des gens assez pauvres pour la
plupart mais qui reste attachés à ce
patriotisme français et à cette liaison
avec la France et donc par conséquent le
passage de la décolonisation on en
parlera dans d'autres émissions bien
entendu et bien se fera quelque part
aussi contre eux c'est ça tout le
problème c'est ça tout le drame et c'est
pas simplement la grosse colonisation
parce que les gros colons ils sont
partis bien avant la fin de la guerre
d'Algérie ils avaient déjà compris pas
mal de choses et puis j'ajouterai que
les colons dans les la campagne
contrairement à ces Européens des villes
et bien ils étaient très liés à la main
d'oeuvre des journées il parlait l'arabe
ils étaient très liés dans les campagnes
c'est très compliqué cette histoire ça
permet en tout cas de figures qui sont
largement longuement évoqués dans ce
premier épisode ils le seront aussi et
pour cause dans les dans les épisodes
suivants je veux parler de faire à Tabas
et Messali Hadj qui sont les deux
grandes figures nationalistes qui
émergent dans l'entre-deux-guerres et
c'est sans doute effectivement dû pour
pour beaucoup à tout ce qu'on s'est dit
avant c'est là qu'on voit émerger le les
premiers courants nationalistes l'un
plutôt favorable assimilation solitaire
à ta basse et l'autre beaucoup plus ils
sont évolutifs sur l'entre-deux-guerres
mais il existe un courant en algérien
avant guerre qui commence déjà à poser
on va dire les jalons la Première Guerre
mondiale pour à peu près tout l'empire
c'est une maman de basculement aussi
bien d'ailleurs en dans de Chine qu'en
Afrique noire qu'aux anti en Algérie
mais et au Maroc en Tunisie mais c'est
vrai que ces deux figures d'abord un
caractère particulier c'est qu'ils sont
très liés à la France aussi ben c'est
pas juste un débat cette fois-ci qui se
passe là-bas c'est à dire qu'on entend
le bruit de ce débat sur la réflexion
sur le devenir en Algérie dans
l'Hexagone ils sont aussi en interaction
avec les partis politiques français il y
a des militants qui sont des
travailleurs immigrés qui sont
maintenant présents sur le solde de
France donc bien que ce débat dépasse
simplement un débat qui aurait pu être
un débat de chapelle et d'élite là-bas
pas du tout il traverse la Méditerranée
il fonctionne sur les deux côtés il y a
une presse il y a des manifestations il
y a des meetings que les gens pensent
que tout est né en fin de compte au
moment des indépendances ou à partir de
54 pas du tout c'est une vie qui bouge
ces mouvements sont pleine évolution
aussi s'adapte vous avez pas eu du Front
populaire le Front populaire est aussi
un espoir un moment de réforme potentiel
ils sont des acteurs de la vie politique
française et là vous avez cité deux noms
mais qui correspondent aussi à cette
présence 40 50 60 000 70 000
travailleurs maghrébins qui est aussi
bien présent sur Marseille Paris et
ailleurs en France qui quelque part vont
d'un seul coup crée du lien et du lion
et vont aussi s'abreuver au niveau des
réflexions de la gauche française par
exemple et c'est tout ça qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que il n'y a pas
quelque part des mondes séparés ces
mondes vont vivre en interaction les
Français vont commencer à entendre
parler de ces élites qui réfléchissent
pour devenir dans la nation et puis vont
se dire tiens il se passe quelque chose
de l'autre côté en Algérie et ces gens
pensent leur devenir ils ont des
porte-paroles qui sont brillants vous
avez cité deux noms qui ont marqué
l'opinion et ils vont tout à fait
rentrer dans le débat politique français
au moins cette entreprise un mot sur
évidemment le massacre de Sétif de
Guelma
notamment qui sont évoqués à la
évidemment à la toute fin de ce premier
épisode pour ce qu'on ne date pas le
début de la guerre de l'Algérie a dit au
8 mai 1945 et c'est maca et c'est
massacres après le voilà ce drapeau
algérien qui qui brandit à Sétif
pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne date pas le
début de la guerre d'Algérie à ce
moment-là précisément est-ce que il y a
une raison particulière à cela compte
tenu de la répression qui a suivi ces
événements 18 mai 45 en Algérie alors on
pourrait effectivement dater le début de
la guerre d'Algérie et du mois de mai
juin 45 ou la répression a été croyable
des milliers des milliers d'Algériens
qui ont été tués mais on garde le 1er
novembre 54 parce que c'est le
changement de leadership politique du
nationalisme chérie c'est-à-dire qu'on
change d'histoire le premier novembre 54
donc c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
c'est à dire que c'est la même chose du
point de vue de du système colonial des
répressions des résistances qui ont eu
lieu depuis toujours mais nous vous
laissent présager une guerre oui ça
laisse présager la guerre mais le saut
qualitatif le tournant c'est le passage
à une lutte armée décidée organisé
réfléchi politiquement ce qui est pas le
cas de mes joint 1945 donc là on est
dans une autre étape notamment parce que
novembre 54 c'est la suite de Diane
bienfu et de la décolonisation de
l'Empire français au sens large donc
c'est pas tout à fait pareil alors on le
découvrira bien entendu dans les quatre
prochains épisodes de votre série qu'on
va diffuser tout au long de cette
semaine
un mot peut-être sur le travail qui a
été réalisé pour notamment illustrer
ces épisodes de cette série beaucoup
d'archives dont certaines inédites vous
les avez trouvées où ces archives
inédites Benjamin store il y a beaucoup
d'archives ça va dans le fond
cinématographique de l'armée française
qui demande encore à être exploité
encore et toujours les archives de Lina
bien entendu là aussi qui demande encore
et toujours à être exploité c'est un
trésor on trouve encore des pépites bien
sûr beaucoup de rushs qui sont
inexploitées etc il y a aussi bien sûr
des archives privés vous savez les
archives c'est pas seulement l'État
c'est aussi des archives privés les
archives familiales autrement dit on en
trouve dans le documentaire qu'on vient
de voir on en trouvera dans le dans les
documentaires suivants il y a beaucoup
d'archives familiales parce que dans les
années 50 on commence à avoir apparaître
le fait que les gens se filment même et
donc il y a par conséquent là à partir
de ce moment là l'apparition d'archives
qui ne dépendent pas exclusivement des
archives d'État
la totalité du travail justement auprès
de ces archives dans le film qu'on a vu
remarquable parce qu'il faut parler
aujourd'hui à une population qui n'a pas
connu qui n'a pas connu l'Algérie
coloniale donc il faut parler à des gens
qui ne l'ont pas forcément en
appréhension donc l'archive est
fondamentale pour faire plonger dans ce
récit dans ce passé là et les sacs sont
remarquables à ce niveau-là et comme une
image un instant il faut l'entendre
c'est un temps de l'image on a
énormément mis en image le temps des
colonies pourquoi parce qu'il fallait
raconter aux français ici ce monde qu'on
voulait raconter d'une certaine manière
là-bas donc à la fois sa fourmille
d'images mais à nous historiens et à nos
cinéastes d'être extrêmement vigilant et
d'expliquer aussi ces images puisque je
le rappelle pour la plupart quand elle
venait de l'État c'était de la
propagande un grand merci à tous les
deux devoir participé à ce débat doc à
la suite de ce premier volet de la série
c'était la guerre en Algérie que vous
avez on le rappelle un coécrit avec
Georges Marc Benhamou Benjamin story on
se retrouvera pour un prochain débat on
parlera cette fois de la guerre en
elle-même 1954 bien sûr
pour réaction j'imagine qu'elles seront
nombreuses ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc
bien sûr sur Twitter merci à sel
massalik comme à l'accoutumée m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission puis rendez-vous
donc pour un prochain épisode de votre
série Benjamin Stora pour un prochain
débat doc avec bien sûr votre
documentaire et un débat à bientôt
[Musique]